من سنين من التسعينات قال ان عدي في اليوم
احنا مجتمعين كلنا ببيت عدي عدي يصوم
اثنين وخميس
فمن بهاي الايام اللي يفطر بيها احنا
العائله الروحي يعني اني وخواتي ووالدتي
واولادنا كلهم يحبوه اولادنا يحبوه خصوصا
البنات عندهم حظوه يمه
ويداريهم وهاديهم ويسولفوا له ويتونس
قاعدين احنا يعني على الطاوله كليتنا بصفا
كلنا قاعدين موجود قال شوفوا يا اولاد
صدام حسين
اموركم ما راح تعيشون حياه طبيعيه ولا يوم
اني ذلك الوقت
حكيت نفسي ليش
يعني الحياه كلها طبيعيه بس قد تكون غير
عاديه
اتذكر كل يوم اليوم
ليش اروح لك على احفاد اني وراء يعني بعد
الدفاع عن الوالد ثلاث سنوات
سكرت مكتب اسناد للدفاع عن الرئيس وجريت
حالي من الميديا ذاك الوقت ماكو
مئه بالمئه ومخلصت قاتلت راح
قتلت دمرت شو السالفه جريندايزر يعني مو
معقوله يعني احنا هسه في وقت اكو رقابه
على الشخص السياسي او من عائله سياسيه هي
مو شغله
متروكه للاقدار
ما عشت ولا يوم حياتي عاديه
اولادي كذلك
اولادنا كلنا كذلك انهم ناشطين على
السوشيال ميديا ما بها شي في هذا العهد في
هاي المرحله
موجوده السوشيال ميديا متوفره بايد الكل
اذا هم حابين يظهرون على السوشيال ميديا
هذا قرارهم اللي اني احترمه لكن حياه
عاديه وطبيعيه يعني
الطبيعيه عجبا كل شخص شلون يقيس معنى يعني
حياه طبيعيه ما اعتقد لا